.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
RACH RAMP ALL RIGHT.
NOW STAYING IN AFGHANISTAN WHERE
THE TALIBAN HAS FORMED THEIR NEW
INTERIM GOVERNMENT, TURNS OUT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS
DUPED BY THE KINDER GENTLER
TALIBAN.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS ANGRY THAT
THEIR CABINET LACKS INCLUSIVITY.
AS IF THAT GROUP, THAT
PERSECUTED WOMEN FOR DECADES WAS
SUDDENLY GOING TO PUT THEM IN
CHARGE OF THE COUNTRY.
WELL IT TURNS OUT THE ONLY
DIVERSITY IN THE TALIBAN'S RANKS
ARE THE DIFFERENT FACTIONS OF
TERRORISTS THEY HAVE IMPORTED
FROM AROUND THE REGION.
HERE TO RESPOND IS DAN BONGINO,
HOST OF "UNFILTERED" ON SATURDAY
NIGHTS AT 10:00 P.M.
DAN, THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
IT SEEMS INCREDIBLE THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ALL THESE
DEEP STATERS WHO CAME FROM, YOU
KNOW, THE WESLEYAN GENDER
PROGRAM.
ALL THESE PAJAMA BOYS IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THAT THEY
ACTUALLY THOUGHT THAT THERE WAS
GOING TO BE THIS NEW INCLUSIVE
TALIBAN GOVERNMENT AND THEY ARE
PRIZED THAT WOMEN AREN'T
INCLUDED?
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
>> THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE IMBISSELLS.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE DUMBEST
PEOPLE ON PLANET EARTH.
THIS IS HOW THIS GOES DOWN,
RIGHT?
THEY DIDN'T REALLY THINK THAT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS AN
ECLECTIC BLEND OF PROBABLY FIVE
OR 600 OF THE DUMBEST PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
AND A BLEND OF VERY SMART PEOPLE
WHO THINK YOU'RE STUPID.
SEE, THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
AND YOU HAVE TO KIND OF PARS
OUT.
I BELIEVE BIDEN IS GENUINELY
DUMB.
BUT THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM ARE
NOT.
THEY JUST THINK YOU'RE STUPID.
SO THEY PUT THINGS OUT ON
TWITTER TO VIRTUE SIGNAL TO
LEFTIST WOKE WE ARE ALL ABOUT
INCLUSIVITY.
EACH WITH THE TALIBAN.
MEANWHILE THEY ARE IN A BACK
ROOM SMOKING AND DISWROKING,
PROBABLY SMOKING CIGAR WITH
COFFEE AND TEQUILA LAUGHING HOW
DUMB PEOPLE ARE TO ACCEPT THIS
STUFF.
BIDEN IS NOT A VERY BRIGHT GUY.
HE MAY HAVE ACTUALLY BELIEVED
THAT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER,
RACHEL, THESE ARE PEOPLE RUNNING
THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW WITH A
ZERO ON THE PRINCIPLE SCALE.
I MEAN, THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY
DID.
THEY ABANDONED AMERICAN CITIZENS
BEHIND ENEMY LINES WITH THE
TALIBAN, A BUNCH OF CHILD BRIDE
TAKING MEDIEVAL SAVAGES.
THEY LEFT OUR PEOPLE THERE THEN
THEY GOT OUT USING CIVILIANS WHO
WENT OVER THERE ON THEIR OWN
DIME TO GET THESE PEOPLE OUT.
THEN THIS BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TRIED TO TAKE CREDIT AFTER
ABANDONING THE PEOPLE FOR
SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T EVEN DO.
I MEAN, IF THAT'S NOT ON THE
DEPRAVITY SCALE A 10 OUT OF 10,
I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FAILURES.
>> Rachel: NO.
ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
NOW THAT WE ARE GONE AND THE
TALIBAN IS IN CHARGE, WE ARE
KIND OF STARTING TO SEE A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF WHAT THE AMERICANS
WERE DOING, WHAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WAS INVOLVED IN WHEEL
WE WERE THERE.
THEY TOOK DOWN BLM AND GEORGE
FLOYD MURAL.
WHO THOUGHT THAT WAS HAPPENING
IN KABUL.
I MEAN, THIS WAS BEING DONE WITH
TAXPAYER MONEY.
AND IT'S SO INTERESTING TO ME,
DAN, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THE LEFT
USED TO TALK ABOUT CULTURAL
IMPERIALISM.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
I WONDER IF ALL THE CULTURAL
IMPERIALISM THAT OUR WOKE STATE
DEPARTMENT WAS IMPOSING ON THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE ACTUALLY
UNDERMINED THE GOVERNMENT WE
WERE TRYING TO SUPPORT?
IT ACTUALLY UNDERMINED WHAT OUR
MILITARY WAS TRYING TO DO.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS ALL BEST UNDERSTOOD
THROUGH THE DAVID HOROWITZ ANTI,
ANTI-COMMUNIST LENS.
RIGHT?
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND LIKE THE
LEFT HAS NO PRINCIPLES.
PLEASE, STOP WATCHING THE SHOW
NOW IF YOU BELIEVE THAT.
IF YOU BELIEVE THE LEFT HAS
PRINCIPLES JUST TURN THE DIAL.
YOU ARE ON THE -- THEY HAVE NO
PRINCIPLES AT ALL.
THEIR PRINCIPLE IS POWER.
THE FACT THAT THEY WILL RUN A
RAINBOW FLAG AND CELEBRATE A
DEAL WITH IRAN THEY THROW PEOPLE
WHO ARE GAY OFF BUILDINGS, I
MEAN, I DON'T UNDERSTAND LIKE
YOU ARE AN IDIOT?
HOW DOES THAT REGISTER?
YES, YES, ALL ABOUT THE IRAN
DEAL.
THEY HAVE LITERALLY THROW GAY
PEOPLE OFF BUILDINGS BUT WILL
WEAR A RAINBOW FLAG HERE.
HERE'S THE THING.
TOUGH UNDERSTAND DAVID HOROWITZ
DESCRIBED THIS A LONG TIME AGO.
THE LEFT DOESN'T HAVE PRINCIPLES
ONLY ABOUT POWER.
WHERE ARE THE ANTI-COMMUNISTS,
YOU AND I?
WE BELIEVE IN FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY.
THE LEFT ARE THE
ANTI--ANTI-COMMUNISTS.
THEY ARE AGAINST ANYTHING WE ARE
FOR.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT -- THEY
WILL SAY ANYTHING TO GET POWER.
THEY HAVE NO BINDING PRINCIPLE
AT ALL.
THESE PEOPLE FOAM AT THE MOUTH
AT THE IDEA OF GETTING POWER IF
THEY HAVE TO THROW LGBTQ LOBBY,
YOU KNOW, OVERBOARD TO DO IT,
THEY WILL DO IT.
THEY DON'T CARE.
YOU THINK THEY HAVE PRINCIPLES,
AGAIN, YOU ARE WASTING YOUR
TIME.
IT'S LIKE TRYING TO TEACH
PHYSICS TO YOUR DOG.
HE IS NOT GOING TO LEARN.
YOU COULD BE THE GREATEST
PHYSICIST IN THE WORLD.
YOUR DOG WILL NOT GET THE
PHYSICS.
LEFTISTS WILL NEVER UNDERSTAND
PRINCIPLES, PERIOD.
PERIOD.
THERE ARE NO PRINCIPLES THERE AT
ALL.
>> Rachel: YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY, VERY
DANGEROUS, DAN.
>> OF COURSE.
>> Rachel: YEAH.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
YOU ARE ALWAYS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE GUESTS.
THAN